e
e e
good
morning it being 10 o' we'll call the
finance committee to
order our day's work today is is to
cover those bills that we put in interim
study there are five bills four bills
that we put into interim study we'll
take them up in order and as published
and uh we'll ask for comments I know
that that uh Melissa Rollins and the and
the LBA and I see Kevin Ripple is here
as well that there's been some further
analyses and we'll ask them to give any
uh analyses and history that they have
come up with all right Senate Bill
453 uh Melissa Collins will'll ask for
your
comments sure so SB the language from SB
453 was amended by um the Senate that
language was put into HB
463 uh and that ended up dying in
Committee of
conference we did speak to um deputy
secretary of state Hennessy concerning
this uh this bill and the funds that are
needed for the election portal and she
stated that they have access to hop Hava
funds to um build the election portal so
this bill probably is no longer
needed further discussions from the
committee yes thank you very much Mr
chair um so I looked into this some more
myself um and I did also talk to um Miss
Hennessy about it they did feel that
there was access to have a funds but she
also said that there's going to be a big
issue with accessible voting machines
she's not sure how that'll play out
whether they'll have to um whether
they'll have to support the towns
because it's going to be expensive
and on balance um my conversation with
her was that she would be supportive you
know of course the devil's in the
details but the secretary of state would
be supportive of reintroduction of a
bill to establish the uh the portal and
to make sure that when it's reintroduced
it's uh combined with the appropriation
amount that was
$450,000 that was in s453
so because the house supported the
passage of the electronic portal and
basically supported s SP
453 despite there was confusion about
funding and amendments I personally
would like to recommend that we
recommend this for further legislation
when combined with the portal and the
appropriation in the same Bill thank you
further discussion from the committee
represent
McGuire thank you Mr chairman yeah I'm
I'm somewhat of the opposite um opinion
here because the the key thing from the
Secretary of State's point of view is
the permission to make these changes to
the voter registration system and this
particular bill is just a straight up
allocate
$450,000 for
the appropriation it isn't the
permission to do the job
because what the Secretary of State's
office said to me was that they may have
Hava funds right and and so the key
thing to them is just the permission
from the legislature to do the job which
was the other bill that didn't pass
right so I would say this one which is
just straight up uh allocating of
money um isn't needed at this time
and you
know money's is going to be tight we
think next next uh year and so um this
could easily uh we we really don't need
this thank
you Bieber well thank you um I mean we
don't have to go too far down the road
on this but I think in the process of
interim study when you're recommending
further legislation you don't have to be
strictly limited to just what this
particular Bill did it doesn't have to
be the exact language so the the
committee could recommend further
legislation that included an electronic
portal with the necessary um
appropriation so that was my thought and
I would make a motion to that effect
okay we have a motion for a further
study is there a
second there's a second and clerk will
call the role on the the motion for
recommended for further study for
further legislation recommend for
further legislation I'm
sorry thank you Mr
chairman representative Earth
no Representative uire no Representative
pidy vots no representative Emer
no representative Griffin no
representative Mooney no representative
Edwards is not here representative Bean
is is not here represent whole
no represent Sween is not
here representative papichi Muller
no representative
walner representative Lehman is he here
no represent buo is
here representative Heath yes
representative
Murray
yes representative eil yes
representative haaken Phillips
yes representative
Stringham yes representative grassy
yes representative priest
yes representative wer
no tide no it's 9
to8 it's what 9 to8 in favor in uh favor
killing the
motion Mr Speaker sorry Mr chair I got
eight to eight
No 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight 17 here 17 n and8
is there he is right there it was 8 to
n98 okay okay which one was Mr
chair I move not recommended for further
legislation all right recommended for
not uh not recommended for further
legislation is there a second second
second clerk will call a roll on that
motion and that was Earth
representative Earth
yes representative Maguire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative em
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Bean uh hle
yes representative uh Popich Muller yes
representative uh
walner representative uh
Heath yes no
no lost
my representative Murray
no representative eel no representative
haen Phillips
no representative Stringham
no representative
grassy no representative Priest No
representative um wer yes Mr shair the
vote is 9 to8 in favor of the
motion okay then that will be reported
out as not recommended for further study
moving on to Senate Bill
553 anybody LBA Melissa
Rollins no for Senate Bill 553 the gist
of the language was incorporated into HB
1241 which was signed into law in August
23rd 2024 there was one minor change in
the original language that um bring it a
little closer to the
sure there was one minor change compared
to what was signed into law which was on
the original bill it said it shall
maintain the PDF shall maintain uh no
less than 30% of the funds held in
essentially New Hampshire Banks
in the language that was signed into law
uh it says it shall strive to place
funds essentially into New Hampshire
Banks and the rest of the language was
the
same so the issue has been put in
another
bill is is what we're hearing any
further discussion representative
papovich mulu since I was one of the
people that didn't like the original
Bill to start with and voted accordingly
I'm happy to make a motion to not
recommend for further study
unfortunately because it already passed
and there are no more there is no more
need for
Stuff motion and uh motion by Papa vichi
muler second by representative Griffin
not
recommended further
discuss Mr not not to be uh super prec
to to it's not recommended for further
legislation not not recommended for
further study thank you for why you had
to correct me sorry not recommended for
further legislation or recommended for
further legislation okay that is the
motion before us not recommended for
further legislation second it
Griffin all right that is the motion
before
us from finance committee Senate Bill
553 is not recommended for further
legislation any further discussion
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
on that
motion thank you Mr chairman
representative F yes representative
McGuire yes representative Petri votes
yes representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Hull
yes representative uh Popovich Muller
yes
representative
Walmer representative uh Heath
yes representative Mary yes
representative eel yes representative uh
hen Phillips yes representative
Stringham yes representa grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
Wilder yes Mr chairman the vote is 17 to
Z in favor of the motion that will be
the report not recommended for further
legislation on Senate Bill
553 we going to House Bill
1595 guess Mr Ripple will give us some
discussion on
that sure yes House Bill 1595 was one of
two bills uh considered this past
session relative to adjustments to the
child support guidelines the other bill
was House Bill
1564 that bill uh was passed and signed
into law House Bill 1595 on the other
hand um had an amendment in division
three that was adopted to essentially
align the two bills and combine them
into
one the finance committee Rec
recommended ought to pass with Amendment
but on the house floor it was
uh uh referred for interim study so
that's why the bill is before you now so
that's the way it came to us from the
house okay further discussion from the
committee
I could make a motion Mr
chair representative Mooney I would move
on House Bill 1595 that it not be
recommended for future
legislation
second motion by Mooney second by Petri
that house bill 1595 be not recommended
for further legislation is there any
further discussion representative H yes
Mr chair I can't support that motion um
we had and PID for a report relative to
child support guidelines at the New
Hampshire level the report was issued in
December of
2022 we spent over $100,000 on that
report I have a copy in front of me part
of this stems
from what 1595 attempted to do that the
bill that ultimately passed did not
which is to set appropriate guidelines
and statute relative
to
parent parental guidelines over number
of hours with the kids and a bunch of
other things in statute we need to do
that we have allowed the judges um a
greater degree of um discretion and that
has created a bunch of turmoil with
families I think we need to take a look
at these guidelines and follow that so I
would recommend that we recommend this
bill for further um
legislation okay but the motion before
us is to not recommend Is there further
discussion on on the two
sides seeing none the clerk will call a
rooll on the motion of not recommended
for further
legislation thank you Mr chairman
representative ver
no represent McGuire no representative
Petri votes
no uh representative U emmer
no representative Griffin
no representa Mooney yes
representative Hall
no representative Popovich Muller
no representative
walner representative um Heath
yes representative Murray yes
representative eel
yes representative hickin Phillips yes
representative Stringham
yes representative grassy
yes representative priest yes
representative uh
Wier
no Mr chairman the vote is 9 to8 in
favor of the motion okay then it will be
reported out as recommended for further
the
legislation further no oh not
recommend counting the thing
yes H not recommended thank you got my
notes wrong here the motion before the
motion will be from the committee on
house bill 1595 not recommended for
further legislation who's
second who who second
no I I did the original motion who did
the uh not rec on 15 she did the
original I did the original motion who
seconded uh I believe it was yourself
you did you did you seriously you were
the second yeah for the original not
recommended but that's the one that
prevailed okay I'll be there I have to I
have to be retrained not
problem the pots right
okay moving on to Senate Bill
230 and the people that made the motion
uh will write the report which is pretty
easy not recommended for further
legislation it's all you need to
say and Senate Bill
239 is the last one we have the use of
harm reduction
Services it came out
um Mr Ripple will give us the
explanations yes uh Senate Bill 239
relative to the use of harm reduction
Services came to finance uh after
passing the house with the floor
Amendment specifically relative to the
definition of harm reduction and after
division 3 held several work sessions on
that definition as well as the scope of
the bill uh the finance committee
ultimately recommended refer for interim
study and that's how it came out of the
house okay
anybody in division three want to make
any further comment representative Hall
is Rec is that representative Stringham
I'm not recognizing whose light is on
there yeah if you remember this bill was
um um you Advanced from the Senate uh
did pass with a strong uh majority uh
before it came to finance um I think uh
the the the issues that led to a one
vote uh uh interim study
are are issues that should continue to
be uh studied and addressed in in future
legislation uh um you know was it was
clearly an important issue uh to be
addressed by this legislative body and
uh one that we should enthusiastically
encourage the next uh legislature to
address and uh therefore I put forward a
motion to uh recommend um legislation uh
U be Advanced um with with the next
banial recommended for further
legislation by representative Stringham
is there a second second representative
priest um my recollection is that it
needed a lot of work on what the
reduction of harm means and it wasn't
clearly defined and I think there are
several other states each one had a
different definition that used that term
so it really needs to be more clearly
defined so the motion before us is
recommended for further
study clerical call any representative
Maguire thank you can anybody tell me um
is there much of a fiscal note on this
bill Mr
Ripple there should be no general fund
impact because the bill requires the
department to establish and administer
Statewide access points for substance
use Services quote with the availability
of sufficient Federal funding so it's
conent upon Federal funding rather than
State funding thank you any further
discussion representative Mooney I thank
you Mr chair I would just add that
Senate Bill 239 an incredible amount of
work was put into this bill its
background the research uh the people
that came to testify in our steady
sessions it's inevitable that this
subject will come up again um depending
on how things are filed for next year so
whether or not our vote is one way or
another
I do believe this subject will be seen
again thank
you further from the committee members
seeing none the clerk will call the role
un reccommended for further
legislation thank you Mr chairman
representative F
no representative McGuire
no reprentative Petri votes
no representative Emer no representative
Griffin no representative Mooney no
Representative hle
no representative Popich meller
no representative
walner
yes representative uh Heath
yes representative maray yes
representative eel
yes representative haen Phillips yes
representative
Stringham yes representative grassy yes
representative priest yes representative
uh Wier
no Mr chairman the motion fails 8 to Z 8
to9 8 to n is there any further is there
a further motion on not
recommended I move that we not recommend
this for future
legislation second representative whole
move is not recommended
representative Murray seconds that was
Murray I'm sorry representative Murray
I'm sorry thought it was Mooney I I'm
pretty sure it was Mooney it was Mooney
what did I say muray no Mooney oh
okay just to be
clear I seconded the motion of not
recommending for future legislation on
Senate Bill
239 yes you did excuse me
all right further
discussion seeing none the clerk will
call a rooll on the vote on the on the
motion of not recommended for further
study on Senate Bill
239 thank you Mr German representative F
yes representative McGuire yes
representative Petri votes yes
representative em yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Hull
yes representative po Muller
yes representative
walner representative uh peace
no representative Murray no
representative eel no representative uh
whoops we at
here repr representative hicken Phillips
no representative Stringham
no representative grassy no
representative Priest No representative
wer yes Mr chair the vote is 9 to8 in
favor of the
motion okay um got down your um your Mo
the winning winning motion maker will
jot down the uh your name and and the
obviously
the vote whether it was recommended or
not recommended looks like every one of
them was not recommended is that
correct U no I think so AE
one uh all not the first
one no that was not
recommended you're right they're all not
all that's what I thought always right
sir at least on the second or third
attempt
thank you all for keeping me
straight but all right so just um those
people that that made the winning motion
just write down the title of the the
house of Senate bill and the fact that
it was not recommended for further
legislation and give that to
U give that to Janet on your way
out is there any further uh to come
before us
motion to
[Music]
adjourn since this is probably the last
time when we are meeting I did want to
thank everybody for U you know helping
me learn so much about the process in
these two years it's my first term and I
want to acknowledge that um some of us
are not planning to return and thank
everybody for their huge contributions
where whether we agreed or not most of
the time I know that everybody work hard
and did their best to make you know this
a better State and I I really appreciate
everybody's efforts thank you we have
kept the discussion
civil and we sometimes agree and
sometimes disagree but we don't hold it
against anybody because sometimes
they'll be with you sometimes they'll be
against you and that's just a matter of
opinion so I appreciate working with all
of you and uh we may have some changes
in in the next session but we will
persevere and we will keep trying to do
our best job to produce a workable
budget for the house and to convince
everybody that didn't sit in with us
that that was the best way to do it
thank you all we are
adjourned
okay e